welcome back to the rock stars this is
the big question another quarantine in
addition to daily dose of distraction
giving you too much information about
the worst crimes committed by your
favorite heroes also the crimes
committed by fictional characters
how you doing Philip good were you about
to admit to something not yet that comes
later in the episode Eric what's my
question well Philip even though we
trust our supers to do the right thing I
want to know when they did the wrong
thing what's some of the most
interesting crimes committed by the
comic-book heroes well I'll say that I
did I did a lot of research on this and
it's not so much that they're the most
interesting crimes
it's the prevalence of crimes that are
committed by our heroes Oh my dad was
the most shocking thing so there was a
study done recently by the American
Academy of Pediatrics which focus on
carrying the kids by the way don't do
Studies on superhero crimes but they did
a study researchers found that the
protagonist in superhero movies
significantly outpaced the acts of
violence that the villains commit in the
same way all right that's horrible
distantly just from a few films the only
superhero films there were over a
thousand acts of the hero starting a
fight followed 659 times by the use of a
lethal weapon sixty-nine the Glover the
199 times destroyed property 168 times
they murdered murderer murdered these
are our heroes significantly outpacing
all the times you see the bad guys on
screen in all of these films I don't
believe this this is the American
Academy of Pediatrics Eric I need to
leave I need to go look at their
methodology on this murder or just watch
killing until the honing it was their
methodology as hash marks
yeah but self-defense ain't murder right
if it's on earth and Chitauri are there
they're trespassing and you have every
right to stand your ground
also still real quick I'm gonna say
pediatrician should not be watching
superhero movies and counting the
violent acts there's a kid in the other
room sees you through the window once to
watch the movie where to but he can't
cuz he's sick Oh God anyway I don't know
why they did this study but it's so real
quick I'll just list
there's crimes that get committed
only by superheroes in my research they
are constantly obstructing justice and
tampering with evidence they break and
enter constantly no warrants they do
commit torture all the time the famous
holding somebody off the side of a
building that kind of thing I like this
one that I found specifically Batman has
committed so many financial crimes with
all the records that he falsifies Wayne
Corp these are like the lower things
that I found just straight up
Superman come hits vandalism we saw this
in Man of Steel where he gets like
really mad at a guy and so he just
destroys his truck oh yeah uses his
superpowers just destroy his truck it's
like that's super level vandalism yeah
destruction of property you can't
believe that think about this too like
this isn't a parking lot there's cameras
he risked his super identity cuz he was
so mad at this guy just key the side of
it a little or something yeah imagine if
you got in a bar fight with someone who
went out to the parking lot and smashed
up their car you would be arrested and
you'd be tried and you'd be in jail and
you have to pay restitution imagine if
you did it with superpowers you would
have so much answering to do yeah you'd
be a terrorist mostly people are but all
right so let's get to the real more
serious crimes that are more egregious
and definitely if you think about it
very problematic and then I'm gonna kind
of describe the crime and then I'm just
gonna highlight there's so many examples
if this list will be endless if I gave
you every single one so I'm just gonna
give you some particularly maybe
unforgivable instances of them or so
what we talked about unforgivable curse
this Dumbledore or is that a different
humble dog Dumbledore these aren't
forgivable Dumbledore Miss Granger
if you avoided last week's episode
because of that thumbnail you have no
idea what we're talking about don't move
that Eric had a stroke last so he can't
read yeah okay first up is just
obviously this category was gonna come
into play just the innumerable number of
assaults and battery that occur that
superheroes guilty of here's what's
really interesting technically it would
be aggravated assault any time they used
their superpowers yeah and you would
think that well they're they're acting
in self-defense
actually that argument would be thrown
out in court because they instigate most
of the fights there would not have been
a
fight if they had just let the crime be
committed that's my problem well could
you give an example of a time where
someone in like the MCU started a fight
I mean technically anything like
spider-man interrupting those bank
robbers and kicking their asses like
what why was he in there right so that's
vigilante justice and from a cops point
of view he would be just as culpable for
being part of that crime as they are and
he gets it gets so much more complicated
but he'd easily be charged with assault
in that instance but here are some some
fun examples well they're not fun I take
that back immediately and when I
remember what examples I'm going to
here's some examples of some bad one one
that was interesting though was
rewatching daredevil the old daredevil
movie with Ben Affleck god bless you
it's for you
if you rewatch it with his lens of crime
committing he brazenly assaults a
strange woman in a park he just like
grabs her oh yes he called her a strange
woman you're kind of victim-blaming here
by calling Jennifer Carter Street I
guess I meant stranger woman and I feel
like saying stranger woman implies that
English was not my first language it
wasn't but I don't really know how it's
a lady stranger stranger stranger women
is our new stranger things spin off
following the or girls from Little Women
she's walking in the park daredevil
grabs her twist her around he does not
know this woman and then she definitely
has the ability to claim self-defense
she kind of twist his arm around and is
like get your hands off of me strange
man with red tinted lenses these oak
leaves out of their time and he kicks
her ass he like fight sir yeah in front
of Whitley playground full of kids right
exactly it's not so just because she can
defend herself does not mean that she's
like allowed to get fought and just on
the street by a stranger so definitely
he'd be charged with assault and he'd be
canceled on the internet completely also
speaking of assault against a woman this
is now one of these unforgivable pretty
egregious ones it's a pretty famous
example too of hank pym beating his wife
he bang waterin in the comics you don't
know about this no look this this is
well this is come the older comics and
the reason why this is such a big deal
is hank pym used to be huge that
character was gonna be like as big as
all the avengers eventually ended up
becoming and his character was trucking
right along and then somebody got the
idea of like we got to make him more
real and authentic let's have him
backhand his wife out of frustration
much like look into that guy first of
all and so he does he backhands the [ __ ]
out of her and everybody turned on the
character like outside of like in our
world people are like this character's
an [ __ ] now and so they started to
try to backpedal and like oh he's
actually complicated and they're like no
we don't like him anymore and they had
to completely reduce the role of Hank
Pym in marble period because of this one
choice where he backhands his wife okay
well you know that makes me feel better
about
the Marvel fan base at the time because
you know fans don't always have the best
track record but the fact that they were
on the good side of history in their
response to that just makes me feel
better about Marvel also I feel better
in like I had Canon of the MCU it's Hank
Pym cuz his wife got back at him by
giving him throat cancer well not only
that in the first ant-man Janet Van Dyne
is missing where he's dead right he's
got this whole story about how she
shrunk inside a nuke yeah okay he got
too little and now you can't find her
and she fell down the stairs into the
quantum realm it's like the staircase
he's in every way yeah a towel attacks
Janet I swear that's Watchmen you think
you know so then the next major category
of crime that I want to go over is just
the concept of criminal negligence oh
sure oh god there's so much blood on
their hands so and that actually that
category has other crimes within it so
once I say this one you'll be like yeah
all of those would be charges criminal
negligence it's anyone who's doing child
endangerment by enlisting a sidekick
that is under 18 years old oh no not
only would it be child endangerment it
also would be criminal negligence all of
Batman's family basically his bat family
and Tony start recruiting a minor to
fight in a war for him against his
friends that's not okay I yeah I mean
you took him to space so so there's that
kind of criminal negligence but there's
also the kind where because they the
ones that have powers know that they
have powers they know that they have
mutations especially the ones that
they're science-based mutations that
means that the very aware of all the
effects think like Bruce Banner has been
very much study the effects of gamma
rays and whatnot so speaking of your boy
spider-man this came up a lot last week
that people were frustrated that we
didn't bring this up the time when Peter
Parker accidentally killed Mary Jane
because of his radioactive sperm oh yeah
that did happen
yeah and that's criminally negligent
because he knows so much about his body
he studied it he's this brilliant
scientist they say one of the most
brilliant scientists
absolutely knows that he's got this all
this radiation that's had these affect
on his body he still gave it to her
anyway at the very least a there's a
lawsuit there you know like you could
imagine the Watson family suing him for
negligence and you can imagine like what
an impassioned speech he would give in
his own defense of like why cuz I loved
too hard
good give her there's all kinds of
people who love too hard and that's yeah
not legal King Kong is not allowed to
get with that girl
this next crime category I thought was a
fun one to just acknowledge how many
times Tony Stark would be charged with
this exact same crime again and again
and again and it is plotting to make
weapons of mass destruction oh yeah
Stark's definitely illegal
it is his main thing that he does right
now to develop weapons is one thing we
have plenty of companies that do that
but he develops weapons that could end
civilization all the time and they often
do try to obviously we saw that with
Ultron sure in the comics you can kind
of parallel the Ultron story with when
he created the Thor robot clone called
Ragnarok now or that's right yeah during
civil wars so actually in that specific
instance but in plenty of these
instances you can also tack on to that
crime because Ragnarok kills black
Goliath who is the Laurence Fishburne
character that we meet in the MCU
Michael eyuth straight up gets like a
hole blown in his chest and he's a giant
form like giant man at the time and he
did can't shrink back down so they just
have this giant body to deal with so
iron man would be charged with felony
murder in addition because his actions
caused a murder he actually was still
directly to blame boy yeah
felony murder is different than
first-degree murder and when that from
true crime podcasts and from what I
thought it was gonna be a lawyer for
that period of my life and gave that up
and when you thought you're gonna be a
murderer yeah yeah I've gotten away with
it okay so speaking of murderer murder
death kill kill murder first-degree
murder right so we went from felony
murder to actual first-degree murders
just so many heroes can be charged with
straight-up first-degree premeditated
murder but I'm gonna just highlight a
couple of interesting examples so you're
familiar with the x-force their deal
with the fact that apocalypse the famous
mutant villain has been reborn it's now
a child and so it's very much kind of
the scenario of the Hitler baby yeah and
they're like what do we do and Fantomex
shoots it in the [ __ ] head just a
little kid yeah and you try to do a jury
that this kid was a reincarnated mutant
god they're not gonna understand that
you know how it's like it there was that
deleted thing with Deadpool where
Deadpool he's gonna go back to kill baby
Hitler huh in this moment with the new
kid apocalypse
Deadpool is there and Deadpool goes I
don't want any part of this and walks
away he doesn't even do it if Deadpool's
not okay with something you definitely
shouldn't do it up next speaking of our
endangered youths from earlier Jason
Todd who was a former Rob and it goes on
to become the Red Hood
and the way he and axe justice is he
decapitates people's illegal you can't
cut people's heads off
unless you're a 15th century French
monarch up next this is such a huge
scale of first-degree murder that I
almost don't even know how to how to
acknowledge the fact that he would get
charged with this you remember wha -
obviously the The Watcher yes humor how
high you ranked is watcher level beans
he's pretty high up there very very very
high up there not many things above a
watcher Nick Fury murders a what just
straight up kills them and scoops out
one of his eyeballs cuz he needs a
replacement yeah right just a giant
watcher I've been like can you tell that
this isn't my yes Nick that does not fit
he just kills a lot - Nick Fury the dude
well I may be a small town ensue lawyer
but I have a feeling that who are - The
Watcher ain't a person and is not
protected under our Constitution yes he
deserved to die and I hope and I'll just
throw in there really quick if you read
Avengers vs. x-men Cyclops just straight
up kills Professor X he's like Dark
Phoenix basically at that point but
still it's Cyclops it's God not only did
he kill someone you killed someone with
with special needs you think professor X
is a special-needs child I'm just
looking at it from an exaggerated view
most jury members are not the most
discernible and they don't understand
the supernatural but they're very
superstitious and very empathetic people
and I'm just imagining the Johnnie
Cochran on the other side of that
courtroom what's gonna be his legal
strategy and he's gonna go straight for
that wheelchair they would just like
paint this like really sad portrait of
Professor X this old feeble man who
raised these orphans yep in this school
and a child endangered then too
yeah and he also committed fraud by the
way because he lies to their parents
about it even be in a school yeah that
would be Cochran's argument defending
Cyclops in this case and then let's go
whole level up here for a second crimes
against humanity these are things that
are just so big that they're they're
illegal like kind of on a global scale I
you can technically say that Scarlet
Witch has basically committed genocide
or you can maybe call it as my cleansing
when she gets rid of 90% of mutants oh
yeah I did look into is this accurate in
the house effects story could you really
call it those things and by technical
definitions of genocide you could say
that that is efforts made to essentially
erase a type of people or like an
ethnicity yeah well that's definitely
what she's trying to do in that moment
or if you want to refer to it as ethnic
cleansing it's trying to remove a group
of people from a place well she's trying
to get mutants off earth basically so
either of those are huge global like
international crimes that she would be
tried for by the UN or something yeah
very high-level crime well think about
it in the x-men movies from the early
2000s that's essentially what Magneto's
plan was with cerebro right like at
first Stryker was gonna identify all
mutants everywhere and wipe them out
cleanse them from the earth and then
magneto reversed it to identify all
humans and cleanse them in both cases
this is the same kind of analog from
like every time genocide has been
committed in human history yeah so we'll
see she might actually do the head and
see you or some version of that yeah I
guess what's the opposite of genocide
love like love making a lot a whole
class yeah let's make a race baby this
a crime against humanity against time
against the multiverse is just the flash
with the timeline so frequently that he
is actually damaged the multiverse the
speedforce
time itself is like unwinding and he
does it all the time flash gun is
obviously maybe the most famous example
of that but he like he doesn't learn his
lesson he just keeps going back changing
time changing everything although we
don't even know what timeline we're in
we're just some like flash farted in
class and went back and undid the fart
and we're from for real no you undo a
fart undo a fart oh God you send it to
me and then I just want to point out one
heroes crimes that are so terrible so
gross but in my research technically not
illegal oh god he's doubt of you in case
you wanted to uh it specifically Hulk in
the old man Logan story we talked a
little bit about in last week's episode
so you know the the most the thing you
referred to from last week is the amount
of incest yeah it's being committed
there right
[Music]
good somebody's lighten my fire
[Music]
you and me all the way
so much for the feeling no pain benefit
Hulk is in Hulk land and this time which
is actually in California yes so looking
at Californian laws actually incest
between even first cousins not illegal
in California what yeah it's illegal
other places but not in California so
call Mindy Eric tell her how you feel no
no she knows how I feel I'm not
interested yeah tell her she's confused
you're sending mixed signals
she just hears what she wants to hear
okay so he does that but also it's the
old man Logan story right so he deals
with Logan he's a like Hulk commits
other crimes that are definitely illegal
but specifically with old man Logan he
does one insane thing he eats him oh
yeah he literally swallows a choose him
up and he eats them yeah the cannibalism
right uh-huh here's the thing about
whether or not cannibalism is illegal
it's not what cannibalism is not illegal
now do you think it's because they want
to protect people's rights to eat
placenta what I mean why else you go -
why else would that be legal what why
you're why are you like yeah well you
gotta eat placenta no I'm digging a knee
why else would someone want cannibalism
to be legal I think it's all disgusting
I don't I don't think it's cool to eat
placenta I think it's gross you've tried
it no I'm not I guess they had eating
placenta it's gross cuz it's gonna
become a thing and then a discord
everyone's gonna say Oh Eric Reese
serious about eating placenta by the way
if you want to be a member of our
discord no okay it's not because people
want to eat placenta okay it's because
they feel like cannibalism doesn't need
to be stated as illegal because if the
person is not dead and you use
cannibalism as the method to kill them
well then that's just murder right you
know it's not such special kind of
murder because you did it a special kind
of way if you decided to do it then
that's first-degree murder
so cannibalism not illegal for that
reason but then if you go the other
direction okay well what if you kill
someone and then you eat them that's
just desecrating a corpse
so that's already illegal in a different
way here's why it's not illegal here
Logan doesn't die when it happens he
survives it and he goes inside his
stomach and he rips his way out and he
kills Hulk so actually how committed no
crime Hulk did nothing wrong so local
family yeah Logan would go to jail for
murder
no I guess you could say Hulk probably
committed assault but when you you know
how the judge uses the scale and puts
one crime on one side and what come on
the other yes that's Weber's gonna
outweigh the assault
that's how the justice system works
right yeah some people and then just is
it that's so extreme I just want to say
really quick it's important to
acknowledge that many other superheroes
commit crimes they are not people you
should look up to speaking of looking up
any superhero that is flying they are
not following the FAA flight regulations
they're putting in planes in danger at
all times I'm looking at Falcon mostly
he could just go in front of a
commercial jetliner throw them off of
course there's all day you know how
complicated it is to plan these
trajectories of these commercial flights
take sure and they're just flying around
like crazy and they're not reporting it
anywhere you saw what just some birds
did to Sully's plane yeah well who
really came out on top there
I think Sully knew dues no thanks he
veered right into those birds the birds
have no one to speak for them because
they can't talk their birds so
superheroes are monsters in a legal
sense
all right well Phillip here's my
question for you Tony Stark snapped the
glove at the end of endgame and he
killed all of Thanos forces presumably
everyone who's loyal to Thanos does that
make Tony Stark a mass murderer does it
technically make him a mass murderer yes
but would he go to jail for it
absolutely not main reason and you
should have learned this in your murder
study if there's no body extremely hard
to prove murder habeas corpus
[ __ ] what does that mean
exactly no body no crime other Bears
know what it means it's you have to have
the person it you can't trial we it
means you can't try someone if they're
not there you can't
yeah it looks someone in absentia but
still nobody no crime
[ __ ] yeah yeah back to the cool thing
nobody no crime alright great well it is
now time to move on to some more
bite-sized questions and we got some
mailed submissions this week so uh hit
me yeah I've got the questions here but
I went ahead and and forwarded the mail
to you I said hold on so I wouldn't have
to touch our thing yeah well Oh too late
so first up I have from Cal mmm soo what
is gamora's sword Godslayer made of it
can kill Asgardians can it kill
Celestials would Thor [ __ ] it up with
God Slayer and never have needed to go
get Stormbreaker Phillip will you open
your mouth a little bit there I just
heard like a tone I had no idea what you
said because we do all of our own
censoring ourselves now during this
quarantine period anyway I assume you
said
okaywell Godslayer what you just said
well god Slayers one of the most
powerful weapons in the Marvel Universe
its substance is undefined but in the
MCU we know of for interesting metals
that are fictional so we have to look at
one we have vibranium
- there's adamantium which I don't think
it has been introduced in the MCU yet
but we know it's coming and then Yakka
that's what oh yeah who's arrow is made
out of so we know Gamora used the
Godslayer to kill the apple esc' all
their other weapons weren't working
that's the one thing that did but when
she tried to use the dagger that was in
the hilt of the Godslayer to kill thanos
it didn't work in the infinity war movie
he had three Infinity stones so maybe it
might have worked if he didn't have the
stones but either way it failed but I
would say if this got Slayer can kill as
Guardians my assumption is that it's
made of uru and was probably forged in
Nitta Valier that's like their big
Armory in the MCU and that's where
everyone goes to get their weapons and
ooh as we know from y'all near Loki's
feared mill near who can kill and as
guardian or someone at that level now
feyo's is not a celestial he's an
eternal with a deviant gene but probably
it looks like he could not be killed
with God Slayer but he was absolutely
vulnerable to storm breaker that's how
he got his head chopped off an endgame
so using that logic god Slayers weaker
than Stormbreaker and when you know Thor
went to e3 and under the valley r2 asked
for the one weapon that could kill fan
those teachers like okay I got one that
can do this it's Stormbreaker so
Godslayer by comparison it's not as
powerful and it probably could not kill
celestial to answer your question so the
one celestial we know who has died at
least in the past I mean ego died in
guardians volume two but the specials
severed head that that became nowhere
that selection was killed by null
that's the symbiote Clint our guide
using comics in the comics he I using
all black the necro sword which that
sword itself was like forged using some
kind of because comics things like the
the shadow of nulls evil spirit the IV
whose Forge was like divine celestial
power it's more than just a physical
sword so that's how that was able to
kill celestial and
interesting Gor the god butcher carries
the necros sword so we might actually
see that origin story in 4/4 from what
happened to nowhere but answer your
question no a god Slayer could not kill
a celestial might be able to kill an
eternal or an Asgardian now I have a
question can you say five times fast in
Thor four she forges Neal near of Ruru
in Nineveh leer that's a lot that's a
lot of words to say anything so in Thor
four she forges Mjolnir and Nidalee
reason uru and Thor Force uses Mjolnir -
nope
and you got the order wrong I'm sorry
I'm ending this call bye so if you want
your rights back and you want Oklahoma
to change be sure and do that for me hey
there's the next question you should
have it there and it came with a special
gift but I'll just say real quick while
you pulled it out
I just simple question which wrestlers
beside Johnson out of the rock I would
make really good heroes or villains in
the MCU okay so this is rich powers a
great name sent us this letter and he
also sent us these awesome enamel pins
that he makes this is a zombie Iron Man
this is amazing thanks dude
I'll be wearing this because if you send
me anything I will wear it on camera
this shirt was also mailed to me by a
musician Christopher James who said you
don't have to promote me but I'm gonna
do I'm gonna give you a shout-out cuz
you're a great musician and he sent me a
shirt send me any shirts guys I don't
want to buy shirts anymore so it could
be sure you already own that you just
don't want to wear anymore I'll wear it
I'll wash it I'll wear that body condom
from last week yeah I'm currently
wearing that it's stretched so thin
alright so wrestlers for the MCU real
good yeah okay interesting question
because the rock and John Cena have both
both kind of set an interesting standard
for playing superheroes the movies so we
have Dave Bautista was a wrestler and
now he's like our MC wrestler
but the rock-like refuses to lose in
movies he refuses to ever play the bad
guy and he is still slated to play black
Adam but he's gonna be probably like an
antihero version of Black Adam so it
kind of limits our options of how we
could see these people but I would like
to see Brock lesner play Ben Grimm the
thing I think he I think his body
structure fits that and he doesn't have
to be a great actor because it could be
covered as he looks like Putin that's
all you really need yes that'd be I
think a lot of the other good roles are
taken I mean maybe AJ Styles is Namor
that could be interesting because it
kind of looks like he could be an
underwater thing and I would say Roman
reigns it's name work but then people
would compare him too much to Khal Drogo
Aquaman
so you need someone who kind of looks
different oh yeah that's true next
question yeah Dave sergeant Wright has
this one also sent you shove the letter
there okay yeah there you go uh if
Johnny Storm loses his voice I love this
question does he lose the ability to
flame on thank you for the
dunder-mifflin letterhead here the
People vs paper people okay so that's a
very interesting question to answer your
question Dave it depends on why he lost
his voice okay so if Johnny Storm lost
his voice by just screaming himself
hoarse at a concert he could probably
still just like whisper a rasp flame on
and still like light up but if the issue
was he lost his voice as it's either a
symptom or a cause of like lost
competence then he might not be able to
flame on because in the comics
whenever Johnny has like inner doubts or
he's not feeling confident he does
temporarily lose his abilities so he
needs to be confident the reason he says
flame on is to kind of just like work
himself up but it's not like the flame
powers themselves are voice activated
like an Alexa or a serie or something
it's he just explanation what if like
macGruber like rips out his vocal cords
well they might die at that point but
like either way I bet you could flame on
as he goes presumably if Johnny Storm
was mute or deaf he could sign flame on
in
flame on that make sense he could write
it down he could text it he could tweet
flame on and he could flame on that's
also how you reverse a fart
yeah you tweet flame on do you have the
the mailbox I do
it's a mailbox a mailbag of fandom mail
sent to us segment yeah the wind calm
still naming it okay running low - if
you guys want to in our discord we were
looking for where specifically as you
know these are the questions that
usually get sent by fans that are asking
us to tell some stories that will get us
in trouble in the future exactly right
this is what you were referencing
earlier this question is just what
crimes have you committed which nice try
FBI they're in the van outside saying
damn we should be social distancing and
if they get arrested by the same band
they're in six vans that are succeed
apart what current I think we got to
tweak it to what crimes are you willing
to admit Alka - on camera yeah obviously
next one yeah I'm not gonna admit to
certain things that I've done like
murder
actually they're canis side there are
six if done that I am never going to
talk about publicly I want to see no you
do not
even if I'm outside of the statute of
limitations it is no one's business and
no I'm not I'm not telling you but there
are something if you think of two that
you've done that I thought you might be
referencing yeah I'm sure there are more
Philip and I both know of crimes that
each other have committed that we are
both using as nuclear deterrence well
well I'll take you down yeah neither
yeah oh one cannot live all the other
survives right yeah we're here my name
is attached to my heartbeat uh-huh black
tie your crime happens to you again and
your crime is like sitting on a dunk
tank that is attached to me that if I
get Goldberg yeah our relationships very
strange so when I was in high school I I
dated this girl like the last couple
months and
I had known her a couple years earlier
we were friends all throughout high
school and I used to tease her because
she had this blazer that she would like
to wear and I don't know cuz high school
guy you have a huge [ __ ] and I just
you know I had two shirts and they were
both for like different plays I was in
and I alternated them and luckily we
were on a block schedule so the kids I
saw on Tuesdays we're not the kids I saw
on Wednesday so I could I could kind of
alternate anyway you've changed so much
you have three shirts now she had
accidentally left the blazer in my trunk
I think we're all like hanging out for
someone's birthday and like I didn't
know cuz I never cleaned out my trunk
you know this about me I never clean out
my car there's stuff in there for years
how we met yeah you were in there and I
freed you she she left it in there and I
didn't realize it was there and then
like two years later I asked her out we
were dating for a bit and then I
realized her blazer was in my trunk but
at that point I had had it for so long I
felt awkward that I hadn't given it back
to her did you say why you stole it I
didn't steal it she left it in my trunk
at first and I think in her mind she's
like oh I just left an Eric's trunk I've
been meaning to get it back from him and
she she just never did and I just like
at that point pretended like she didn't
do it because my mom eventually did
clean up my trunk and she hung it up in
our closet in her house so I was like oh
I've accidentally stolen her blazer but
then the fact that you didn't alert her
means you do no longer than ever right
yeah but then I denied it that's the
thing she started asking man you lied I
lied and she asked she's like to get my
blazer and I said no what are you
talking about she's like Eric I know you
have my blazer and then that thing
happened like months later she was
hanging out with a bunch of her friends
and she called me and she got and you
could hear all the friends laughing in
the background
she was Eric why did you steal my blazer
and I said I didn't who told you that
and then another friend I had who knew
that I had had it cuz I had confessed to
her that I accidentally kept stole this
she's like she's the one who told her so
I got pissed off at that friend we broke
up a month later for other reasons I'm
sure I'm not so sure I think this was
like the main reason that
yeah yeah I just felt so guilty and then
I denied it
I kept it even after we broke up him
like I didn't steal your blazer but then
I was going to college to meet you and I
eventually returned her blazer I put it
in a brown paper bag and I left it in
our drama club classroom for her to find
but and the did you want it to be like
you did that as a nice thing or like
look you stupid idiot it was in the
classroom the whole time how dare you
accuse what I did is I left it with this
apology notes saying I'm so sorry that I
lied to you I should have told you the
truth I didn't mean to cause so much
drama in your life and your drama then
at the end I signed it the name of the
other friends I blamed it on her have
you ever considered what she thought you
were doing with her blazer I try not to
think about it Philip yeah absolutely
was like what is he doing with it and
they're like you know what he's doing
and I'm sure she loves that I tell this
story publicly now when I was very
little like like five or so that's not
that little I guess I was at my aunt's
house and she had this nice hedge like
bush thing that was like instead of a
fence between her and her neighbor and
my sister was playing near it and she
called me over it's like Oh what is it
and she was playing with matches okay
and she was lighting individual leaves
on fire and then you know she was stupid
I guess and so she didn't think of how
that would like go back into the hedge
not like 45 seconds later the whole
hedge is on fire like a wall of flames
drowning all the length of the house the
fire department has to come that light
they have to put it out I guess I'm
crying out of shock remember I'm in one
of those like space blankets later and
I'm like cool I don't really know about
like what happens with the fallout is
about this until later I find out that
my from my mom that you know she's like
you know it's like that fire you started
that want to end I'm like wait what are
you talking about turns out I found out
my sister had told everyone that I had
started that fire and my aunt believed
that and my
mom believe that and no matter how
desperately I was like I didn't start
that fire they'd never believe me so
that was like in my head for a while so
not too long after that in Miami
I was playing and there was like that
like some woods behind our apartment and
I kind of just was like well if they
already think I'm a firestarter and I
started a little spire there with with a
lighter with some matches and I also AM
dumb and did not think that I would
spread and I started a forest fire it
was on the news what it it wasn't it
wasn't so bad that like like animals
were displaced or anything no of no
because it because I lived in a very bad
area so there's not enough trees next to
each other animals are like that book
those ghetto animals they were they were
like very tough about it they lit their
cigarettes on the fire it like was just
definitely this section of this area and
there was like a helicopter like doing
like footage or whatnot but I was like
six or something but I definitely was
guilty of arson that's a six year old
and that one I feel like my family did
know I did but because to them that was
the second instance and not the first
they just like didn't bring it up and
they were like let's not antagonize him
or they were afraid of I didn't they're
like wow you can torch anything yeah
yeah you know now that I think about I
did burn that snowman that I tell you
burnt the Snowman Danny built he burnt
that film real with your mind oh yeah by
the way a lot of people that no one here
knows that snowman story and they're
like how do you person
[Laughter]
it's just what campfire do I'm so
impressed by it it's beautiful - you
wanna burn a snowman it's easier than
you think you just start with the limbs
those do burning carrots breath it gets
hot enough
yeah and coals scream his eyes all the
rest of his body melted
well that's again I feel like every week
we find a way to really put our lives
and careers in jeopardy Philip I think
this is one-sided I always say something
I think that is horrifying
you stole this girl's blazer she was
gonna do plays an entire forest now she
she had a baby and married instead you
just you first you set this girl's life
floor of course
really honestly they should call you the
Blazer instead of what the news media
got me a monster
they know the Blazer you know you're a
Philip you're a good example of what's
wrong with the criminal justice system
once they take out 11:3 and they and
they tell them they are a certain thing
they're more likely to be repeat
offenders because in their minds they
feel like well I'm a criminal so I guess
I'm gonna be a criminal isn't a dull
anything I've ever been called I double
down on well that's our show a writer
that you can help us go even deeper down
these dark paths by becoming an official
patron and you can join us on discord at
patreon.com slash new rock stars on
there you can submit questions but also
I want to challenge you guys to ask a
question that's really gonna put Eric on
the spot I can't I can't be this bad
yes you can you could be worse well you
can get audio versions of this show by
subscribing to new rock stars on
wherever you get your podcasts the big
question is the name of the show
Thanks to everyone who submitted
questions this week especially those who
mailed
stuff in we love doing it and we love
getting mail from you guys you can send
in mail at our p o-- box address listed
down below and send us questions on
twitter everywhere by using the hashtag
big question you can follow me at EA bas
follow philip at philip milena and you
can follow new rock stars in social
media and subscribe here on YouTube to
get much more information on all the
stuff you care about even the horrifying
crimes that people commit that you don't
want to think yeah yeah tell us in the
comments what crimes you've gotten away
with yeah and your home address in there
alright see you guys next week
[Music]